c'est le jour de relevage des filets
pour tirer la loire a monté d'un mètre
suite aux fortes précipitations et aux
lâchers d'eau de barrage en amont l'eau
va très vite au collecteur principal qui
est qui est la loi et il n'est
absolument pas retenu donc les les eaux
ne font que passer on a des vagues ne
peut dépasser vague de crues parce qu'on
n'a pas eu cru la mêlée les montées
d'eau passe par vagues très très vite
donc concernant la pêche c'est très
perturbant et mai mais au-delà de ça ça
permet pas la recharge des nappes de
chevannes seulement pour aujourd'hui
pas non plus de 6 durant vu les super
prédateurs sont pourtant très présents
dans les eaux ligérienne au détriment
d'autres carnassiers les cendres et les
brochets dont la population est en fort
déclin ils subissent chacun des effets
du changement climatique des chances
d'aider des effets des des niveaux d'eau
dire que le brochet par exemple les
besoins que ses frayères soit en haut au
moment où justement il ferait mais au
moment où il fait froid il arrive que
les périodes ne coïncident plus les
poissons migrateurs montrent aussi à
l'appel les aloses les anguilles il n'y
avait pas assez d'eau au moment de leur
migration vers l'amont du fleuve pour
thiery il s'agit maintenant d'économiser
la ressource
il nous faut perdre ce sentiment de
d'abondance pour deux nouveaux porter
attention à la ressource et voir comment
on peut l'utiliser au mieux et la
respecter pour tous ces usages